hello everyone and welcome to the most
awaited game from the round 4 of the
2022 us Championship it is former 2700
player Han smoking Iman vs former 2800
player and former video World Chase
Championship Challenger Fabiano caruana
it's quite the game features a very
exciting line of the names of Indian
there's quite a lot quite a lot of
theory like the first 20 moves are
Theory but then it gets very very
exciting so let's dive straight into it
and see what Hans prepared for Favi or
maybe what Fabi prepared for Hans so
here Ponte D4 we have Knight to F6 like
we've advertised it's going to be a nice
name so Indian C4 E6 Knight to C3 and
Bishop to B4 the names of Indian defense
is on the board and we have Queen to see
to the classical variation so if the
bishop ever captures you can capture
with the queen you don't have to mess up
your Pawn structure we have Castles by
Fabi A3 and Bishop captures and C3 Queen
captors and now the five the Noah
variation Bishop to G5 now asking uh how
does black want to play this you could
play an ibd7d captures or you could
challenge the bishop right away kind of
forcing uh the captain F6 so Bishop
captures Queen characters and now Knight
to F3 by Hans the characters on C4 we
have Queen characters and not Knight the
C6 we have Queen back to C3 this is the
top engine move and it is the standard
move in this line everyone plays this
with Rook to E8 and now Rook to D1 uh we
have Pawn to E5 now as the white king is
still in the center of course Fabi wants
to open up the position but this is also
Theory Pawn to D5 chases away the Knight
Knight Knight the B8 so retreating to
the starting square but you are
preparing C6 to challenge White Center
and now here in this position E3 or E4
are the moves that are played you could
play E4 which is nice defense uh D5 also
prevents the bishop to F5 but hanza goes
for E4 he wants to develop the light
Square Bishop he doesn't care about
Bishop to F5 so that's how Fabi develops
it with Bishop to E2 and now Knight the
D7
so kind of saying are you maybe
interested in a nice nice capture on on
C7 but if you capture on C7 then you
just allow uh black to to develop with
mini Tempe for example Rook rookie to C8
now you have to figure out where to put
your queen then The Rook comes the C2
and especially if you capture the other
one then it's just Knight to C5 and then
once Knight the D3 check or or okay
Knight to D3 for the moment isn't
possible let's say queen to B5 you can
play Rook 8 to B8 challenge the queen
and after let's say queen to A5 now the
Capron B2 and you've given Black full
development
um uh so not not really worth it you you
can't Castle the bishop will be hanging
so it would be well close to winning for
black if if not outright winning so
instead after 97 uh we have just Castles
by Hans and now Rook 8 to C8 defending
the pawn here preparing to open up the
position with C6 and now there are some
games where Bishop to B5 was played and
it does make sense you you prevent C6
you also pin the Knight so the Knight
cannot move but here Hans plays Ponte A4
and it is now as of move 17 that we have
a completely new game so this A4 idea
goes well with what actually happens in
the game as Hans wants to play A5 A6 and
mess up 5V spawn structure so he can
take advantage of the weakened pawns so
here we have Pawn to C6 Fabi of course
once done uh challenge that strong D5
pawn and now Hans has to make a decision
does he want to take for example
captures captures Queen moves somewhere
uh let's win before put pressure on the
B7 Pawn then Hans can Fabric and
defender or something but instead he
plays Pawn to D6 and this is a very
committal move because although the pawn
is on D6 it's a pass Pawn so it's very
close to promotion it's very easy for
black to organize and attack against
this Pawn even the Knight can
uh if you manage to remain over the
night all the way to F5 then the Knight
can also help out so this Pawn is likely
to fall the question is what can Hans do
with all the time the pawn is alive so
here Rook C to d8 by Fabi we have Ponte
A5 preparing to mess up five spawn
structure with A6 with Bishop to g45 he
wants to get rid of the Knight here H3
and the bishop captures and F3 now uh
Hans could play Bishop captures but then
he allows Fabi this very nasty formula
which forces a queen trade and it's not
something that you would enjoy for
example captures captures let's say
Bishop G4 now Rook E5 is possible going
after the pawn and now A6 is met with
this very nice B5 and okay it's a game
but uh the the pawn is still weak it's a
fairly easy to organize and attack
against the pawn and if the pawns start
marching forward it will also be easy
for Fabi to create a pass Pawn of his
own so here Hans captures with the Jeep
on he plays G captures and the bishop
here will be used
um I had to control the queen side so
nice to f8 uh Fabi continues
re-maneuvering his Knight so he can go
after the D6 pawn queen to B4 now
putting pressure on B7 and just Rook to
D7 we have rooked the D2 preparing to
double up here and now while Fabi could
play A6 and say okay I'm not giving you
any Contra play Fabi says nope you can
do that I'm just going after the D6 Pawn
so Knight the G6 Rook after D1 now the
d-pawn is nicely defended but the
problem is
uh it's on a dark Square so Hans cannot
defend it with a light score bishop and
Fabi can attack it with the Knight and
with the both Rooks and with the queen
so the four attackers versus three
Defenders the pawn will surely fall so
Knight to H4 uh with tempo as it attacks
the F3 Pawn as well Queen to G4
defending on F3 and now just to Rook the
E6 adding another attacker to the Pawn
King the F1 sidestepping any nasty
checks and now Knight to F5 and from F5
the Knight now completes its long
journey and is attacking the D6 Pawn
socket the D6 Pawn will fall but Hans
did what Hans wanted to do he will mess
up fabi's Queen side so B captures
Bishop captures and now we have Rook D
captures on D6 we have Rook captures on
D6 and now natural captures but here
Fabi decides to keep the Rooks on the
board Place Knight captures and D6 and
now what do you play here we have Bishop
back to D3 now also you could consider
some like Bishop T2 if you want to add
more uh the defense the pawn here also
Queen B4 is very nice put some very
unpleasant pressure on the on the Knight
here maybe Queen to B8 check you can
eliminate the pawn but it leaves the uh
the king side unguarded so while it is
possible and it's a perfectly fine move
Hans goes for Bishop to D3 instead uh G6
now you don't want this diagonal uh open
as long as Hans has a light Square
Bishop so G6 we have Ponte H4 hoping to
get H5 in but Fabi just closes it pawn
to H5 we have G3
and now King to G7 and okay the position
is now uh uh very nice for Fabi he's up
a pawn and Hans has to figure out how to
play this and he plays Pawn to E4 and
while this does restrict the movement of
Black's pieces it also pretty much
destroys his own Bishop now the light
score Bishop isn't really doing anything
and um okay uh you've taken away these
scores from the Black Knight and even
though the Black Knight could uh enjoy a
nice Square on F4 it's very hard to
actually get the Knight there there's no
Square from which you can get it to F4
so okay E4 does serve a purpose queen to
E7 uh we have Queen to G5 Hans wants to
trade queens now but Fabi says Nope now
as you are out of uh attacking options
the queen side is completely blocked uh
I'm gonna the king said is completely
blocked I'm gonna shift my attention to
the queen side so Queen back to C1 Hans
has to defend the pawn queen to B4 and
now uh we have Queen to D2 offering a
queen trade and okay Fabi says there's
no other way to push forward we have
captors captures and King the F6 now
preparing G5 which will surely create a
past H Pawn so here Hans glow spawn to
B4 always an important move controlling
C5 and A5 so uh Fabi can't just start
pushing pawns G5 with Rook to A2 now
going after the A7 pawn and now just
Knight the C8 and here a very
interesting thing happens Bishop to A6
attacks the night Knight back to D6
busher back to E2 by Hans and Knight
back to C8 by Fabi defending the pawn
but now Hans doesn't repeat Hans
actually pushes for more he plays F4
so even though he's down a pawn and he
is uh uh well in in an endgame where he
is basically defending he is uh he's
willing to push this for more than a
draw so now he's attacking the H5 pawn
and Okay g captures on H4 if you go for
uh some other capture it's not going to
be as great uh so G captures on H4 First
bishop captures an H5 and now Knight to
D6 now Fabi can abandon the defense of
the A7 Pawn as the E4 Pawn is also
hanging so now Rook captures an A7 he
captures an F4 first we have F3 now D4
Pawn is defended and now Rook to E5
attacking the bishop here Bishop to G4
and now Knight the C4 with some nasty
tricks of Knight to E3 check attacking
the king maybe trading off the Bishops
and it's not easy to continue the game
for Hans in the game Hans played King to
G2 but the very interesting was Rook to
A6 as the pawn cannot move and now even
if Knight E3 check King F2 and now you
capture this bishop with check F
captures and now Rook captures on e4 uh
the thing is you don't go for this
capture and allow King to G5 you first
play King to F3 you chase away the rook
and only after The Rook defends this
Pawn now you play King captures and F4
so that's one way to play this
but after Hans is King to G2 fabi's
position definitely comes alive he plays
Rook to B5 now puts pressure on the B4
Pawn Rook A4 defending the pawn and now
okay you can chase away The Rook with
Knight B2 because this will be a problem
uh but but also just Rook a sex can go
go after the pawn yeah this isn't really
a problem yeah if you go after Knight we
can just play Knights the D3 and it's
perfectly fine so okay it just Knight
goes rugos to A6 and nothing really is
happening here so it's better the way uh
floppy played it he goes Knight to E5
King to H3 now hoping to grab the H4
Pawn but just King to G5 defending it
and now uh Rook the A8 as there are no
active moves here so he will try to go
after the H Pawn this way now Fabi grabs
the B4 Pawn Rook to h8 and now King the
F6 and now the problem is there's no
good way to capture the H4 Pawn if you
capture with the King just Knight G6
check Forks to the King and The Rock and
if you capture with the Rook then Rook
the B1 and now you have all sorts of
problems uh the thread of course is just
winning the rook and even if you move
the king just C5 and the C Pawn marches
forward
so after King to F6 uh we have rooked H5
now threatening some very nasty Rook F5
check ID as the King has to move then
the Knight hangs so now Rook the B5
defending the Knight and Rook F5 check
King E7 and now Bishop to H5 so putting
pressure on F7 the Knight now cannot
move but that's just the thing the
Knight can move now interestingly here
King the E6 is um I'll try to winning
for Fabi point is that after Rook
captures an F4 and there really isn't a
better move there's this very nasty
Knight D3 attacking The Rook ended the
bishop so you have to play Bishop to G4
with check or or Bishop captures on F7
doesn't really matter but after King F7
uh now comes Rook F5 and after Rook
captures an F5 Bishop captures their C5
and there's no good way to stop the pawn
uh if you want this diagonal to open up
you have to play E5 and then the Knight
just gobbles up the pawn you can't play
F4 because then I just gobbles up the
pawn and black will be up to many pawns
so after for page 5 we have knighted the
G6 instead by Fabi and this sort of
allows Hans back into game Bishop
captures on g6f captures now root
captures and F4 and pawn to G5 so Fabi
manages to save his H4 Pawn Rook to G4
and now King F6 defending the pawn Here
and Now Hansa does not wait any longer
here hunts should go with Rook to G2 or
Rook to G1 and just um
uh fight uh uh uh against the the past C
Pawn but here we have Pawn to F4 and now
Fabi has a very very clean idea on how
to win the game but it's not easy to
understand why so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move that wins for Fabi while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that The
Rook on B5 is very vulnerable and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is a rook the B3 with check and
to understand why this is very important
uh the problem is if we go g characters
on F4 right away then look at this Rook
captures an F4 King the E5 and now look
at this Rook captures an H4 and now C5
uh White starts the uh run with the King
you want to get as close as you can to
the C pawn and now black loses this very
valuable tempo of fanta C4 because now
Rook H5 check will win the Rook so
that's that's kind of the point uh here
you have to realize that you have to
move the roof from B5 before actually
capturing here so Rook B3 check uh we
have King the H2 and now comes the
crucial part of the game Fabi now
doesn't play G captures on H4 which is
now winning as The Rook is not
vulnerable here in the line that we've
shown but instead he plays Rook the B2
check and this allows Hans to play King
to G1 which keeps him in the game but
Hans doesn't go King to G1 uh hunt just
goes back King to H3 point is after King
to G1 and you start pushing C5 you can
play Rook captures on G5 and now c4 is
met with Rook to C5 so everything is
nicely defended uh so King the H3
instead by Hans there's even a moment of
this let me just uh uh let me just check
real quickly if you guys are interested
I can even show you this moment
uh just give me a second I have it
somewhere here uh yeah I think this is
it there we go
uh so here you can see
uh probably will now deliver this check
the The Rook is on The Rook is on B3
uh Fabi now gives the check and Hans
immediately plays King H3 so he took
like two seconds to decide on the move
which was not enough King to G1 was much
much better but what you're gonna do
this is move 60 so yeah you have to play
it but now Fabi repeats Rook to B3 with
check King to H2 and now Fabi doesn't
miss uh the second time G captures on F4
Rook captures an F4 with checking the E5
and now rooked captures on H4 and now
there are two ways of winning this one
is to play King the D4 which is very
nice because you just start pushing the
C pawn and if E5 is ever played you just
capture it the white king is too far
away the other way is to do it the way
Fabi did is to go after the pawn but
this is a bit slower here Rook the H6
goes after the pawn now Rook C3 and now
if hunt repeats Rook the H4 then you
have to play King to D4 and just leave
the pawn B but Hans plays King to G2 and
now King captures an E4 we have rooked
the D6 cutting of the black king but now
King to E3 rookie 6 checking to D2 Rook
to D6 track King to C2 and Hans gets the
uh come closer with the king king F2
Pawn to C5 Rook to C6 and now King to D2
cutting off the white king we have
rooked the C8 uh Pawn to C4 we have
rooked the C7 Rook the C2 and now Rook
the D7 check Fabian was the king with
checking C3 check we have King to E1 and
now Rook the H2
uh so how do you how do you continue
this uh King to D1 of course Hans would
enjoy having his King in front of the
pawn but just Rook the H1 check King to
E2 and now King the C2 preparing to push
the pawn to C3 Rook the D3 checking to
B3 now the pawn prevents Rook to D3
checks so Hans needs to go all the way
back now Pawn to C3 another problem is
uh although you kind of want to play
King to D3 uh you cannot because Rook
the D1 check wins The Rook here so
instead we have rooked the B8 with check
uh King to C2 and now Rook the A8 and
here after Rook the H7 uh it was in this
position and move ad that uh hunts
Neiman resigned to the game and Fabiana
corvana is the winner of this very nice
clash in round four of the US Chess
Championship 2022 so quite a wild game
very nice line of the nice nimso indian
uh hunt really tried to start some
trouble with that D6 spawn push really
weak and fabi's Kings a queen side but
Fabi captain on he just continued
pushing and in the end that well
basically there were a few moments but
uh yeah I had Hans defended well uh
would be would be would be a draw but uh
he didn't so Fabi was was able to grind
it out but it took 80 moves which is
very very nice and now yeah there's
really nothing you can do after Rook to
H7 uh whatever you play you you can make
a rooking you can make for example we
said you're gonna play King the B2 now
Rook the B8 to check you're gonna play
King to c one another Pawn comes to C2
and so on and so on and not not much to
be down there you can even go Rook to
each to check here if King to E3 you can
go Pawn to C2 and now uh there's not all
that much you can do if Rook to D3
you're just gonna play King to D1 and
this is a neat little trick now you will
Queen the pawn even if the pawn is
captured now you just play Rook H3 check
kick away the king from the defense of
the Rook as all of these squares are
covered so you have to move the king now
King capture so now you don't promote
the pawn but you actually check made the
white king so there are many ways to
winning this depending on how white
would defend
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it with this win Fabiano is now
in Seoul lead of the US Chess
Championship 2022 with three full points
out of four five followed by Samuel
Savion with two and a half and then a
whole lot of other people on two points
so we're going to discuss the standings
in a bit more detail but after a few
more rounds are played uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it again
big congratulations to everyone who
founded that pause the video moment
because it was not an easy one uh F4 is
very nice by Hans and it should lead to
a draw but Fabi found why why it doesn't
just I mean a wonderful stuff this check
is he he really had to see that the Rook
would hang there you would be too slow
to push the C Pawn I mean this is uh
truly brilliant stuff so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jose Palacio Chris Mullen GJ red
rose and Kerrigan for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I think thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that is happening in the Chess World so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day